das klingt erst mal ziemlich verrückt
aliens könnten versteckte botschaften in
unseren genen hinterlassen haben
der astrophysiker paul davis hält es für
möglich dass außerirdischer bereits vor
langer zeit nachrichten in unserer dna
in unserem erbgut versteckt haben und
sucht nach solchen relikten überlegener
intelligenzen steckt die antwort nach
der frage ob es außerirdisches leben
tatsächlich gibt schon lange in uns
selbst und tatsächlich ist es ja schon
gelungen informationen in der dna
abzuspeichern klick zum science fiction
die geschickt die spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen weltweit
suchen forschende nach beweisen für
außerirdische intelligenz mittlerweile
wurden auf dieser suche unmengen an
beobachtungsdaten zusammengetragen schon
knapp 2 petabyte diesen unglaublichen
schatz an daten hat jetzt eine private
initiative namens break so listen
öffentlich zur verfügung gestellt ein
teil der daten kann sogar von jedem den
es interessiert ganz einfach über das
bürger forscher netzwerks seht rom der
universität von kalifornien eingesehen
werden city steht für search for
extraterrestrial intelligence also der
suche nach extraterrestrischer
intelligenz das ist die größte
veröffentlichung von daten die es im
city netzwerk je gegeben hat ein
großteil dieser daten kommt vom parkes
radioteleskop das in australien steht
und vom greenback radioteleskop aus den
usa diese teleskope haben die letzten
vier jahre lange nach funksignalen von
der milchstraße gehorcht während
forschende des city projekts die riesen
datenmengen durchforsten hält es der
astrophysiker paul davies von der
arizona state university für möglich
dass außerirdische längst nachrichten
auf unserem planeten hinterlassen haben
könnten und zwar in uns menschen genauer
gesagt in unserem menschlichen erbgut
david ist direktor des centers for
fundamental konzept in science und
leitet seit 2005 ein forschungsteam das
erarbeitet wie wir reagieren sollten wir
tatsächlich beweise für die existenz von
aliens finden
er ist der meinung dass eine klare
definition von leben
bei der suche nach außerirdischem leben
helfen könnte für ihn spielt dabei nicht
nur eine ansammlung von molekülen eine
rolle sondern auch der organisierte
austausch von informationen auch unser
erbgut ist ja nichts anderes als
information codierte informationen die
auch wieder decodiert werden kann
die entscheidende frage ist wie diese
erste codierte informationen des lebens
entstanden ist und ob es grundlegende
gesetze gibt nach denen dieser prozess
abläuft davis meint dass die suche nach
außerirdischen an den enormen schritt
machen würde wenn man solche gesetze
finden würde den fund von mikroben auf
dem mars sieht er zum beispiel als
hinweis darauf dass leben im all
mehrfach entstanden sein und sich zu
intelligentem leben weiter entwickelt
haben könnte außerdem wissen wir dass es
ja einige erdähnliche planeten gibt was
wir aber nicht wissen ist ob sich in
ähnlichen verhältnissen entstandenes
leben auch zu komplexe intelligenten
leben weiterentwickelt oder ob unsere
evolution nur ein zufall war
wobei so wie es im moment aussieht gibt
es ja wahrscheinlich milliarden planeten
im all und auch eine riesige zahl an
erdähnlichen planeten also selbst wenn
es also zufall war
während die chancen nicht klein dass
dieser zu fall auch noch x-mal im
universum stattfindet einfach mal so von
der wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung
ausgegangen der prozess der evolution
ist uns bereits bekannt die
ursprüngliche entstehung von leben ist
die große unbekannte die davis lösen
möchte er glaubt dass wir die gesetze
dafür in den nächsten zehn jahren also
vermutlich bevor wir außerirdisches
leben aufspüren finden werden doch wie
können solche gesetze aussehen die
definieren das leben entsteht die idee
ist dass diese neuen gesetze abhängig
vom zustand der materie sein können das
macht sie um ein vielfaches komplexer
als fixe gesetze die wir kennen wie zum
beispiel unsere physikalischen gesetze
sie sind dynamisch und davis erklärt sie
anhand eines schachspiels indem man bei
den gleichen spielfiguren die regeln
ändert wenn ein spieler der zwei bauern
weniger hat als sein gegner
seine übrigen bauern nicht nur vor
sondern auch zurück bewegen darf er gibt
das völlig neue spielsituation
so etwas könnte auch bei einem lebenden
system passieren und würden wir diese
gesetze finden
könnten wir tatsächlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit von leben konkret
berechnen davis meint dass wir lange
versucht haben nach gezielten signalen
von aliens zu suchen dabei brauchen wir
diese laut davies eigentlich gar nicht
außerdem sind sie sehr unwahrscheinlich
denn wenn aliens uns an funken würden
würden sie das nur in der annahme tun
dass wir die signale auch empfangen
würden diese technologie also
funksignale nutzen wir aber erst seit
100 jahren also würden außerirdische
sich nur auf diese art melden wenn sie
sich im umkreis von 50 lichtjahren
befänden
nur dann hätten sie ja eine chance eine
antwort zu bekommen 50 jahre signalweg
in 50 jahre signal weg zurück 100 jahre
seitdem eben der funk entdeckt wurde
oder von uns benutzt wurde
astronomisch gesehen ist das unsere
direkte nachbarschaft und deshalb eher
unwahrscheinlich stattdessen
konzentriert sich eine neue art der
suche auf relikte also spuren
intelligenter lebewesen und zwar in
unserer engen umgebung in unserem
sonnensystem es könnte schließlich sein
dass aliens vor langer zeit vorbei
gekommen sind und uns bereits
botschaften hinterlassen haben dabei
findet davis vor allem die idee des
genomischen sehr interessant die geht
davon aus dass eine überlegene
intelligenz eine nachricht in unserem
erbgut hinterlassen haben könnte das ist
wirklich eine ziemlich verrückte idee
zum beispiel eine auffällige ab folge
von buchstaben die wie primzahlen sind
die menschliche dna wäre perfekt für
außerirdische um botschaften zu
verstecken informationen lassen sich
leicht in ihren verstecken und sie
bleibt über jahrmillionen erhalten fun
fact dass sich informationen im erbgut
verstecken lassen hat der amerikanische
biochemiker craig venter bereits
bewiesen er hat seine eigene e mail
adresse in ein genom eingebaut davis
scheint ziemlich praktisch veranlagt zu
sein
in dieser art der suche nach unbekannten
leben im all sieht er den großen vorteil
dass sie nichts kostet man braucht keine
riesenteleskope oder
teilchenbeschleuniger gene werden
ohnehin sequenziert die suche nach
botschaften aus dem all kann man also in
einem aufwasch mit machen genauso
praktisch findet er auch die möglichkeit
relikte zu suchen
die als artefakt von außerirdischen auf
dem mond hinterlassen wurden den
quartieren wir für andere projekte
sowieso in hoher auflösung da kann man
diese bilder auch gleich für jedermann
zugänglich machen und zum beispiel
auch in schulprojekten nach verdächtigen
spuren suchen lassen für wahrscheinlich
hält der forscher es übrigens nicht dass
wir solche spuren finden werden zitat
eigentlich glaube ich selbst nicht daran
dass es tatsächlich anderes
intelligentes leben im all gibt aber ich
bin offen dafür ein aufgeschlossener
skeptiker sozusagen
es macht unwahrscheinlich sein und
verrückt klingen aber faszinierend ist
der gedanke dass in unseren eigenen
genen botschaften aus dem all stecken
und verrückter als die idee
außerirdische schicken uns ganz gezielt
radio botschaften ist es wirklich nicht
aber wie sehen aliens aus team von aster
comics zeigt euch da ein paar ideen
anklicken anschauen und unbedingt
abonnieren mega kanal bis dann bleibt
dran